for marco gonzalez his 21st start 7-5
record a 4-2-5 era for marco
85 strikeouts over 33 walks opponents
hitting 251 against him
302
and swinging a miss murph drops throws
to first
and there's one now
arson bidding for one more right here by
a diving dylan moore it's off the wall
in left carson kelly a line drive two
out double
and he's at second base for christian
walker
he's done most of his damage this year
against lefties that's why he's batting
third tonight
he's hanging up kellner giving chase to
the gap he's got room
stranded at second nicely done by marco
gonzalez no problems in the first inning
see if the mariners can get the offense
crank in here and get off to a good
start against arizona
t-mobile park in downtown seattle where
your ram truck starting pitcher for the
diamondbacks is madison bumgarner the
last three outings have been a struggle
losses at pittsburgh in philadelphia jp
crawford nine hits on a road trip that's
why you take your time but i mean once
you get in you still feel it most oh
look at this he felt this one high drive
right field
it is gone one nothing matters what a
start
jp crawford
smooth with his eighth home run rbi
number 45.
he's been swinging the bat well lately
at a home run on wednesday
[Applause]
pops it up rojas at third
[Applause]
brush off that lead off home run j.p
crawford gets his eighth
and seattle has the early lead
rohan's at first base ahead of henry
ramos
reaches out and pokes it to left field
there it goes henry ramos his first big
league home run
and the diamondbacks take a 2-1 lead
ellie did a lot of that in reno and he
waited a long time for that moment right
there henry ramos
that's number one
boy hank
two and two
slow breaking ball hit the tie
he'll take it two run homer by ramos
gives arizona a 2-1 lead when we come
back abraham torros
gets battling the ball with regularity
he'll lead off for the mariners
see if tom murphy can drive in a run for
the mariners tom hitting seventh in the
lineup
that is rightful
down the line say goodbye
turn it over
his tenth oh running the mariners are
back in front three to two
tom murphy
oh that thing leaped off his back
rbis 29 and 30.
good for the mariner veteran catcher
nicely done
runner goes what a break demo to second
hey
this is the reason why he likes to go in
the first move lake comes up he takes
off and he does the right thing just
keep on running
following the murphy home run
fastball by crawford mad bum gets the
strikeout but seattle gets the lead
right back they've homered twice
and lead it 3-2
quick move to first and gonzalez throws
it away
france a little slow to get up martay
will head for third
and he's in there standing up
that's an error on the pitcher gonzalez
looked like ty france got a little
tangled up down there and was slow to
recover
and carson skies one deep to center
field kellnick is out there martay's at
third and here he comes
diamondbacks capitalize on the second
seattle error in the ball game and now
we've tied it at three
swinging a miss mad bum has set down
four strange got three strikeouts and
after three
we're tied at three in seattle
[Music]
there's only drafted by the red sox
slices one right field here comes
hanniger he's there
runners stranded
in a 3-3 ball game when we come back
abraham tour lewis terrence and tom
murphy
hit his home run about three sections up
[Applause]
that stays fair for roja steps on the
bag
and they get two
and kelvik skies it to center field
cattell marte should have room here
and he does
after four diamondbacks and mariners
strike three call got it nicely done by
marco gonzalez
big strikeout his third of the evening
score remains tied
goes good break same situation as last
time and he's in there again safely
demo
[Applause]
i'm not sure bumgarner was he wasn't
going to go to first
he saw dylan take off and that's when he
threw it over there
arizona three unearned runs instead of
sac fly
from kelly
and he could not make the play and
america's going to have the lead at 4-3
time france
brings home dylan moore the mariners
have a 4-3 lead
3-2 pitch
nice
you stop building your position as easy
as it gets right there one two three six
well done by marco gonzalez a 4-3
mariner lead
this time murphy two-run homer on an 0-2
pitch looking for murph to pull
he drives one instead of deep left
center field going back round mouth look
for the two home run ball game
the murph makes it 5-3 mariners
boy he's come out of his shell this last
week or so good for tom
2-2 from settler with two out
hey get him
casey sandler job well done in the
seventh inning we go bottom seven
stretch time here t-mobile park
seth fear making his major league debut
brought up from aaa reno today
seth beer hits a fly ball deep right
field it's gone
seth beer a home run in his first big
league at bat
welcome to the major league seth beer
how about that
good on you seth beer congratulations
first of many barriers up a run top nine
here we go a ball of two strikes he got
him four game over murders win it five
to four
you